we are facing a national crisis and if
we do not ascend to the levels in which
we were threatened at the Great
Depression we were threatened in World
War two if we tell the American public
that we are more willing to invest and
bail out big banks than we are willing
to invest in our farmers and our urban
families then I don't know what we're
here doing calling climate change an
existential threat to humanity
congressional Democrats introduced a
policy proposal in February called the
green new deal which would mandate that
100 percent of US energy production come
from clean renewable and zero emission
energy sources like wind and solar by
the year 2050 but some environmentalists
say green new dealers are neglecting one
obvious source of abundant clean energy
already available nuclear power would
swim the conservation is begin
environmentalists and everything like
that because it stopped being about the
environment ironically
controlling society michael
Shellenberger is a lifelong
environmentalist and founder and
president of environmental progress a
pro nuclear research and advocacy
nonprofit based in Berkeley California
he believes that increasing our reliance
on nuclear power is the only way to
combat climate change and has become one
of the leading pro-nuclear voices in the
media in the effort to try to save the
climate are we destroying the
environment well I think nuclear is the
best for inherent physical reasons with
nuclear it means that a single can of
coke provides enough uranium to provide
all the energy that you need for your
entire life and then after you're done
after that's done splitting the atoms
and releasing heat that becomes the
waste Shellenberger started his career
in energy advocating for more government
subsidies for wind and solar he pushed
for a new Apollo project modeled on the
original Apollo moon mission and sought
three hundred billion dollars in federal
research and development funding to make
renewable energy sources cheaper than
coal within a decade well fund the
Apollo projects of our time at the
California Institute of Technology
they're developing a way to turn
sunlight of water into fuel for our cars
from 2009 to 2015 the Obama
administration took up that call and put
billions of dollars into renewable
energy subsidies which Shellenberger
says opened his eyes to the reality that
no amount of government funding can
solve the inherent drawbacks of
renewables during that time we started
to see the various problems that a lot
of people are familiar with already with
solar and winds they require huge
amounts of land and thus trigger a very
significant local opposition as well as
opposition from conservationists who are
worried about the impacts on threatened
and endangered species and then the
other one is just the unreliability of
solar and wind it means that when the
Sun is not shining the winds not blowing
you always have to have some backup
California invested heavily in
renewables which he says led to energy
price increases at a rate about six
times faster than the national average
despite the falling cost of solar panels
the point of renewables was always to
create scarcity and high cost
electricity that was the benefit that
was view
as the feature not the bug of renewables
and and decentralized low energy living
in the 60s it's only recently that it's
been dressed up as a kind of form of
abundant energy but everywhere we see
that the consequences of doing
renewables at significant scales is the
same which is to make electricity
expensive if you want to save the
natural environment you just use nuclear
you grow more food on less land and
people live in cities it's not rocket
science the idea that people need to
stay poor that's just a reactionary
social philosophy that they then dress
up as a kind of environmentalism
Shellenberger calls his pro-growth
urbanist vision of environmentalism eco
modernism congress member Alexandria
Acacio Cortez and her allies on the
other hand he associates with so-called
dark green environmentalism it's very
romantic view you know Ewok Society
basically returning to kind of a small
farm or agriculture tends to be very
negative very apocalyptic very utopian
very dogmatic how much of that do you
attitude do you think persists today
100% I mean I think it's shot through
the core motivations of all of the
leadership of the environmental movement
now what they do though because that's a
minority view I think it's an unpopular
view among most people what they then do
is they go dress up their anti-nuclear
stuff and all sorts of nonsense they go
and tap into people's unconscious fears
of the bomb that's really the main event
the anti-nuclear energy movement was
informed by the Cold War reaching a
fever pitch around 1979 when the China
Syndrome West release which explored the
possibility of a nuclear plant meltdown
leaking radiation deep into the earth
and poisoning the groundwater
still problem
twelve days after its theatrical release
the u.s. experienced its first nuclear
plant meltdown at Pennsylvania's Three
Mile Island at about four o'clock this
morning two water pumps that help cool
reactor number two shut down officials
say some 50 to 60,000 gallons of
radioactive water escaped into the
reactor building and that the
radioactivity penetrated the plant's
walls there were no casualties and has
had no detectable impact on the health
of workers or nearby residents but it
marked the beginning of the end for
nuclear energy development in America no
new nuclear plants have been built in
the US since and 19 have been closed
China Syndrome completely framed our
perceptions then the no news festival
which was an anti-nuclear energy rock
concert but in it has a nuclear
explosion and mushroom cloud in the
background so there was always an effort
to kind of make people think of nuclear
war and nuclear weapons associated with
nuclear power plants so it's basically
been a huge concern troll for like 60
years you know misinformation propaganda
really attacking nuclear because it's a
source of abundant energy the connection
isn't that the nuclear plants are going
to suddenly blow up like bombs or create
bombs but that you can take the nuclear
materials from the plants you already
have them sitting right there and
develop them into bombs and right we've
seen that to varying degrees what do you
say to people who are worried about
nuclear non-proliferation think nuclear
energy runs counter to that I mean the
first thing you have to realize is that
nuclear weapons spread right there used
to be one country with nuclear weapons
now there's nine nothing we can do about
that we try but if a country really
needs a nuclear weapon like North Korea
is scared that it could be invaded like
the United States invaded Iraq it's
gonna get a nuclear weapon if we had all
these nuclear wars have they been used
in wars have they made more wars no we
see from 1945 to today radical declines
in deaths and Wars and battles so I
think that the underlying fear of
nuclear energy is nuclear weapons and
the underlying fear of nuclear weapons
proved to be completely unfounded these
have been weapons of peace
not weapons of war this may HBO is
dramatizing the worst nuclear meltdown
in history Chernobyl in the Soviet Union
in 1986 some of them will not stop
firing for 50,000 years but
Shellenberger says Chernobyl's
implications are widely misunderstood
when I started to change my mind about
nuclear I just went and read the UN
reports on Chernobyl yeah that's the
worst nuclear accident I think it's fair
to say it will be the worst nuclear
accident that ever occurs why do I say
that because there was no containment
dome it was literally just the reactor
caught on fire shot radiant material
into the atmosphere threaded all over
the world so it's inconceivable given
the advances in the technology that we
could have an accident like that again
so you look at the worst accident and
according to the best available science
somewhere around 50 firefighters died
immediately putting out the fire or a
few years later and then about a hundred
and fifty people will die from thyroid
cancer there were several thousand
increased cases of thyroid cancer yes so
there were estimates that the number of
thyroid cancers could reach something
like 16,000 so the theme of thyroid
cancer is that nobody should ever die
from it it's easy to treat you just
remove the thyroid gland and then you
take a synthetic thyroid substitute and
so the people that will die from thyroid
cancer are people that don't get the
health care that they need and so on the
one hand you kind of go did they die
from the thyroid cancer or do they die
from lack of medical care I mean it's
shockingly benign technology when you
really look at it I mean when you
consider the fact that killed on coal
mine accidents 7 million died from air
pollution fuel rods are now exposed and
if they stay that way they could release
radioactivity and a disaster of unknown
proportions in 2011 three reactors in a
nuclear plant in Fukushima Japan melted
down after an earthquake and tsunami hit
the country about 1,600 elderly Japanese
nursing home residents died during a
botched emergency evacuation and a
financial settlement was reached with
the family of one potentially radiation
related cancer death and contaminated
cooling water made its way into the
Pacific Ocean with the Fukushima
disaster one of the worries is that this
stuff is gonna get into the ocean and
have long ranging effects that we don't
even know about yet is there Fukushima
radiation in the ocean absolutely we can
detect it we can detect it off the west
coast of California the question is are
those levels of radiation very high
they're not they're very low the ocean
is so huge the earth just you know the
solution the pollution is dilution right
that's the first thing you learn in your
eco bio class in college and so
radiation just ends up diluting over
huge amounts of areas and that's why we
know it doesn't have much impact
radiation from nuclear plants basically
never kills anybody it just attracts a
lot of our fears for kind of historical
and cultural reasons fear of nuclear
power not only caused Americans to stop
opening new plants but to decommission
old ones Rancho Seco a nuclear plant
constructed by the same firm that built
Three Mile Island was shut down by a
local referendum in 1989 after
experiencing a cooling malfunction a few
months before the Chernobyl meltdown
though it's abandoned exhaust towers
still loom over farmlands in the
northern California town of Herald
voters and citizens in Sacramento
decided that the nuclear plant there was
just too risky given its history in the
1980s Edie smell off was the sole member
of the Sacramento Board of utilities who
favored closing Rancho Seco today he's
an advocate with the lobbying group vote
solar I met up with him at an old Ford
manufacturing plant across the bay from
San Francisco that's been partially
converted into a solar power plant where
smell off once worked did you sense any
fear in the community of nuclear yeah
there was an element of the community
that were worried about a nuclear
accident particularly because this was
the same plant it's Three Mile Island it
was a big demonstration there in 1979
after the meltdown at Three Mile Island
so I would say maybe a third of the
voters there
this is the regular alert for contra
Costa County it's not the kind of sound
I want to hear what I'm talking about
nuclear yeah Rancho Seco closed 30 years
ago and only now is Sacramento's Utility
Board close to reaching an agreement
with another firm to store its nuclear
waste which currently sits under guard
in a storage tower at a cost of about
five million dollars per year you have a
source of contamination radioactive
spent fuel that needs to be cared for
for a hundred thousand years and how we
pass that on from generation the
generation without damaging the
environment or damaging damaging future
generations is not known so nuclear
waste is the best kind of waste that we
produce from electricity production why
do I say that well the first reason is
that they're so little of it all of the
waste from nuclear energy production the
United States can fit on a single
football field stacked about 50 feet
high it's in canisters we've looked
really hard we haven't found a single
person that's ever died from it if you
were to fantasize how would you want
human waste to be you would want it to
be contained you'd want to be small
compact you would want to not pose any
harm to anybody basically that's what
only nuclear has achieved nothing else
really has achieved that smell off says
she favored shutting down Rancho Seco
less because of safety concerns than the
economics of plant operations Rancho
Seco experienced more than a hundred
unplanned shutdowns in its 15 years of
operation beginning in the 1980s with
the passage of some federal legislation
it opened up a wholesale market so it
created market alternatives to nuclear
power what you're implying there is that
there can be no real market in nuclear
that it assesses a monopoly is that
accurate I think it's generally right
there's the risks associated with
nuclear power require that the entities
that own it have really deep pockets and
the way these plants operate sometimes
with extended outages can have really
significant impact on the financial
returns nuclear energy does not
in very well with the market approach to
the extent that other countries that
were nuclear have transitioned away from
nuclear towards renewables the energy
price have gone up and in California
we've seen our energy prices spiked
significantly since there's been
investment in renewables so from a
consumer perspective is an investment in
renewables versus nuclear going to hit
us hard in our pocketbooks so I think
the fact that Germany and to a certain
extent California were early adopters
that is they took the initiative to say
we're going to promote wind and solar
even though it's more expensive than the
alternatives is now paid at all paid off
15 years hence Germany shifted energy
production from nuclear to renewables
and energy prices shot up to nearly
double that of neighboring France which
stuck with nuclear France continues to
source ninety-three percent of its
energy from low-carbon sources the
majority being nuclear while now only 38
percent of Germany's energy sources are
low-carbon the German publication Der
Spiegel recently published a cover story
critical of the country shift to
renewables featuring a drawing of a
broken windmill the unreliability is the
main event solar and wind are producing
a lot of electricity when you don't need
it and not enough electricity when you
do so on the issue of it producing too
much electricity you have to literally
pay people to use it
it's called negative electricity pricing
because the grid has to be perfectly
balanced between supply and demand
so Germany's been paying its neighbors
to use electricity just like
California's been paying Arizona to use
electricity or paying big industrial
consumers to use it and then when you
don't have electricity then you have to
pay us basically a second time for some
backup power that problem is not going
to be solved by having Cheaper solar and
wind and you can even argue that cheaper
solar and wind allowed them to make
electricity so expensive because it
created this illusion that they were
super cheap but as soon as you put them
on the grid you had the high cost of
managing their own
very little land is needed to get rid of
old fossil fuel electricity generation
in the United States
that flew square there is land area
that's needed to transition the United
States to a zero carbon electricity
situation it's really not much most that
area is gonna be in rooftops Solar
advocates say that it's really all about
the batteries and Elon Musk is gonna
create super batteries that allow solar
to work if you just take all of the
batteries in California including all
the batteries in our cars and you were
to use them to backup electricity you
would still have less than 30 minutes of
electricity backed up but when you're
talking about powering the entire
economy on solar and wind you would need
to have backup battery power that would
last weeks and probably months so you're
talking thousands of hours it's just
beyond the realm of possibility the cost
would be in the trillions the vision
that I think I'm seeing from solar
people is a more decentralized approach
way up the battery walls on your home
right then I guess there would be a grid
but much less strain being put on the
grid it's basically propaganda and I
actually did focus groups in our office
and as soon as you introduced the idea
that everybody would have batteries and
solar and will be off the grid people
just fell in love with that idea and
like literally there's nothing we could
say that would change their minds it's
just something about it I think it
appeals to libertarian you know it
appeals to it's very American I you know
I find people like on Twitter and social
media who will say things like well we
don't need nuclear because you know I
have solar panels you know at my house
and it's really cheap and it's like well
did you know that we were that all of
your neighbors are subsidizing your
solar panels and that in fact your solar
panels depend on the grid I mean it's a
fantasy and I blame you on musk for
actually promoting it it's just clearly
in his business interest to do so but
it's just incredibly expensive
Shellenberger concedes that nuclear for
the time being requires subsidies though
he says that the unnecessary shutdowns
of operational plants across the country
have contributed to the high costs but
he is skeptical that the mark
alone can provide a clean energy future
if nuclear necessitates government-run
program or a very monopolistic program
are you all all worried about just that
kind of concentration of power and
control especially over something like
nuclear material so my my friends that
really are libertarian they really love
their freedom or whatever is that hey
you know if you want to go off-grid go
off-grid like there's nobody preventing
you from going off grid but then don't
go make demands on the rest of the
society to subsidize your lifestyle
choice right that would contradict the
whole idea if you want to achieve these
social and environmental benefits of
clean cheap electricity then the society
is gonna have to make a choice to do
that I mean there's no alternative to
it's not going to be done in this kind
of distributed way because it's not
that's just not how electricity works it
is the best kinds of electricity are
centrally produced but distributed
broadly if nuclear is not really
attracting private investment and other
types of energy such as natural gas
which does have fewer co2 emissions than
coal or other fossil fuels why not just
let the market play itself out and move
towards natural gas I'm a huge fan of
the fracking revolution that we've had
it's just opened up abundant natural gas
natural gas is better than coal unlike
every metric to build pipelines and move
that gas across lands you have to get
the society's permission you have to
cross public lands a lot of the gas and
oil drilling is on public lands what
about the oil and gas revolution itself
it's always been supported by public
investment I mean there's just a million
ways in which the public is always
involved in energy production the
neoliberal approach would probably be
you know a carbon tax if we're worried
about co2 emissions and then kind of let
it all play out from there do you think
nuclear would thrive under that kind of
system I mean for sure nuclear would do
better if there was a price on carbon
and so in that sense I'm fine I'm in
favor of it I mean the problem is is
that I've been doing this work now for
15 20 years and every time people
propose that it just ends up being
really unpopular I think once people
understand that the technology is good
not
bad then we'll end up accommodating all
these different things that you would
need to do in order to move to it in the
same way that we did when we figured out
the natural gas was good or at least
better than coal nuclear power provides
about 8% of the world's energy down from
seventeen and a half percent at its peak
in the 1990s though countries like India
and China have begun to invest heavily
in the technology and states like New
York Ohio and Georgia continue to
support nuclear investment with
significant subsidies while energy
secretary Rick Perry has promised to
make nuclear cool again presumably
through a combination of deregulation
and federal subsidies California
continues to invest in renewable energy
and plans to shut down its last nuclear
reactor in Diablo Canyon by 2025
meanwhile thanks to the fracking boom
the Energy Department forecasts
increased US oil and gas production well
into the coming decades people are dying
this is serious Iowa Nebraska broad
swaths of the Midwest are drowning right
now underwater farms towns that will
never be recovered and never come back
the real reason they hate nuclear is
because it means we don't need
renewables
[Music]